이번에
뉴욕의 두 번째 오셨잖아요 세 번째요
작년이 두 번째고 첫 번째는 언제셨죠
첫 번째는 2016년도에 처음
뉴욕으로 왔었던 거고 그때 이제 느낀
점이 많아서 아 내가 나중에 꼭
성공하면
뉴욕에 꼭 진출해야겠다
2016년에 오셨을 때요
[음악]
날 따라오는 거 아니었어요
[웃음]
오늘 제가 그 뉴욕에 와서 협력하는
플래티넘 플라퍼티 대표님을 모셔가지고
지금 뉴욕
시장이라든지 이런 전반적인 내용에
대해서 한번 좀 이야기를 나눠보도록
하겠습니다
회사 소개랑
본인 소개를 간단하게 좀
부탁드리겠습니다
[음악]
마지막으로
현재 뉴욕 부동산 시장의 현황과
앞으로의 전망에 대해서 설명해 주시면
좋을 것 같습니다
[음악]
[박수]
박진우 부사장님을 모셔서 뉴욕 지금
시장이 좀 어떤지 거래할 때 어떤
프로세스를 좀 갔는지 좀 오늘 설명을
들어보도록 하겠습니다
영상을 보고 계신 적이고 구독자분들도
뉴욕시장에 관심이 있다라고 하면은
그런 절차들은 좀 어떻게 되는지
설명해 주시면 좋을 것 같아요 사실은
물건은 와서 이제 보셔요 만약에
뉴욕에 계신 상황에서 연락을 주시면
저희 사무실 이곳에서
간단하게 이제
어떤 니즈를 받으신지를 좀 파악을
하고 서울에 계신 분들은
통화를 통해서 저희가 좀 그런 부분을
파악을 한 후에
리스팅을 좀 보내 드려요 이제
실질적으로 방문하는 동안에 업데이트
된 리스팅을 받고 저희랑 투어를
하세요 우리 어저께 말씀 나눴을 때도
나왔던 얘기지만
매입을 해서 나의 소유로
넘어오기까지는 여기는 시간적인 부분이
한국보다 좀 길어요
투 좋은 물건 본인이 마음에 드시는
물건이 있어서 이제 이걸로
진행합시다라고 하시면 그때부터는
바이어를 내포지션팅 하는 브로커와
셀러를 대변하는 브로커가 서로 이제
내부를 하기 시작하거든요 그래서 2주
정도의 그런 레고 시간을 갖고
기본적인 가격이나 여러 조건들이
협의가 되면 이제 변호사가 연관이
돼서
계약서를 주고 받게 돼요 유리한지
불리한지를 판단을 해야 되는 부분들이
있어서 그런 변호사 분들이 리뷰하고
서로 의견 교환하는 시간이 2주 정도
계약서 사인을 하면서 이제 계약금을
지불하게 되세요
한국은 사실
라고 하면 당일에도 처리가 되는데
어쨌든 뉴욕 부동산을 산다라고 하면은
제가 봤을 때는 그래도 한 두 달
정도 한두 달 정도 두 달은 여유를
갖고 들어올 수 있는게 맞을 것
같아요 지금 만약에 뉴욕에
투자란다라고 하면은
어떤 걸 좀 투자하면 좋을지
오피스가 들어가 있고
밑에 상가가 들어갔던 그런 혼합용
믹스 우즈 빌딩이 요새는 나쁘지
않아요 왜냐면 가격이 워낙에 좀
다운되어 있습니다
리딩 시장이 지금은 되게 좋은 기회로
보입니다 만약에 뉴욕에 투자한다라고
하면 뭐 최소 현금양 같은 거
덤벨으로 기준으로 좀 괜찮은 곳에
투자하신다고 보시면은
150만불 150만불
정도로 부동산을
투자용으로 사신다고 하면
추후에 현금화 할 수 있는
방법이 좀 쉬워야 되는데
그러려면 임대도 잘 돼야 되고 많은
사람들이 선호를 해야 돼서 그래서
투자로 오시는 분들은 저는
프라임 로케이션에 프라임 빌딩의
프라임 유닛을 사시는게 가장 안 좋은
하고
추후에도 좀 더 많은 이득을 보실 수
있을거다라고 말씀을 드리는데 지금
말씀드린 부분은 그냥 기본적으로
보시면
좋은 위치에 좋은 빌딩의
빌딩 안에서도 가장 좀 선호되는
유닛을 하시는게 가장 좋았잖아요 그럼
임대료가 어느 정도 나와요
150만불의
기준으로 보면은 저희가 한
7천 불 정도
맨하탄의 콘도는
지출 중에 가장 큰게 부동산 세금
빌딩
매니지먼트한테내는 커먼 차지 관리비이
두 가지가 가장 커요
여러가지가 있는데 이런 건 다
차치하고 그냥 아주 큰
텍스 하고 커먼 찰지만 보고
임대료를 수입으로 본다고 하면
매입가 대비 수익률은 2%에서
2.3% 정도 보시면 될 것 같아요
다 현금으로 사셨을 때
요새는 임대료가 많이 올라서 2.5%
이상 되는 물건들도 있어요
근데 이제
기본적으로 가장 좀 평균적으로 봤을
때는 2.5% 미만으로 보시면 될 것
같아요 임대 수익 그래서 만약에
이제이 영상을 보고
부사장님한테 이렇게 좀
문의를 하고 싶다라고 하면은 이메일
주소랑 그 내용에
띄워드릴테니까 이쪽으로 문의해 주시면
되고 구독자는 아주 미미하지만
저도 조그만 유튜브 채널을 하나
하고요
뉴욕 부동산에 그래도 관심은 있으세요
관심도 있으시고
실제로 투자도 한 경우도 꽤 있어서
지금이 영상을 보시는 분들도
조금이 뉴욕 시장에
당장 투자하지는 않더라도 좀 관심갖고
지켜보시면 되게 좋을 것 같고
그리고이
뉴욕 시장을 통해서 또 배우는게 되게
많은 것 같아요
시장이 좀 이렇게 흘러가고 있구나를
또 많이 배우고 있어서 시장
예측이라든지 뭐 이런 것도 좀 가능할
것 같습니다
뉴욕 시장에 대해서 저희 박진우
부사장님이 좀 많은 얘기 해주셨는데
만약에 뉴욕 부동산에 관심이 있으시면
저희 부사장님한테
문의를 꼭 주셔서
구독자로 꼭
얘기해 주셔야지 아무래도
신경을 많이 써 주실테니까 저희
구독자라고 해서
연락 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다
동생 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다